coming to you live from Baton Rouge
Louisiana down here that Mary Chris
Greece Christmas Day see I want to let
you know that I one time I this many
years ago I I was trying to go to an
orgy in Los Angeles you know like a sex
you know like a sex orgy and they made
you audition to go to it and I went to
the audition and they said that I didn't
have nice enough calves that I don't
have you know I guess basically my
calves my cavalry isn't welcome at a at
a group [ __ ] if you will that group sex
and that kind of you know you never
really get that no out of your system
happy holidays Merry Christmas let's get
in to it
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what let's try this one there
we go
take you back to church you know see a
little hottie across church
went get hit wink at her or him if he's
you know if you're really
thinking while
[Music]
oh right you know you'd think I'd have a
better intro here at Christmastime here
on the holiday but I do not welcome to
this past weekend I'm Theo von I am
going to be you know getting us through
it and I'm coming to you from Baton
Rouge Louisiana
in case you hear something in the
background if you hear a couple of
alligators kind of you know talking to
each other like this or if you hear
maybe a little crawdad kind of you know
pinching his cousin or if you hear
somebody who can't you know maybe
somebody who can't read or write very
good but they still got a big smile on
their face then that might be the
background of Louisiana behind me
soaking into this microphone man
Louisiana is something else you know
it's something else it's one of the 51
of the 50 states it is it's it has one
of the largest ports in the world along
the Mississippi River Tom huckleberry
Tom and Huck stayed here Jim you know
darker Jim and Tom and Huck and Mark
Twain remember that what else a lot of
great stuff here in New Orleans and in
Louisiana I'm down here in Baton Rouge
spending time with my family but yeah I
try to go to an RG one time in in New
Orleans and I Los Angeles sorry a long
time ago and and they said I didn't have
a nice enough Cavs you had to really I
guess you had to look a certain way and
man it just yeah I never forget that I
never forget that I don't I don't have
that body I don't have the body that's
welcome at a group [ __ ] you know I got
that one-on-one [ __ ] body and that uh
as a man you never had never really
escapes you
so Merry Christmas it is this will be
Christmas Eve today it's Christmas Eve I
want to remind you that the King and the
sting podcast starts tomorrow and that
will be on its own unique YouTube and
audio channel podcast channel it's a
trial episode so you know we have some
different elements and stuff in there
that we're just practicing with and
we're gonna learn as we go and please
check it out on YouTube if you get a
chance and let us know your constructive
criticisms and you can see some of the
visual effects and whatnot but good to
be here and joy to the world you know
it's nice to be here in the south and
you know around the holidays and just be
around the family and today everybody
you know we did Christmas today and
everybody was running around and opening
opening gifts and they had a dog
somebody came from Utah and they brought
a dog and somebody they had two cats
here when I'm named Meno and that's got
to be alarming when you think about it
to a cat because cats love fish you know
if you had to think of if you if you
offer two cat five different things if
you granted a cat five wishes five of
the wishes would be fish all five of
them so when you name a cat after a fish
that's got I mean that's torturous
really it's really a torturous thing to
do and they did that to this small cat
and they had various cats at the
Christmas we did today
various cats what else you know it
reminded me joy to the world it's a good
time now's the time of year when you can
hug somebody if you see somebody and
they look like they haven't been hugged
or you know like their breath stinks or
whatever or they just need a a little
pick-me-up go hug them you know put your
hand on your bat on their back while
you're talking to them
you know maybe whistle a tune when you
walk packed past their desk at work
maybe whistle a tune whistle something
throw a little joy over by him write joy
on a piece of paper and ball it up and
throw it at them and when they open it
up what's their sheer joy written out
joy it's just that time of year when you
can touch another person on the face
that you don't know lightly and say I
wish you well brother I wish you well
sister I hope that the joy finds you I
hope the little baby of the Lord crawls
into your heart and lays eggs of
happiness and joy it's that time of year
go tickle somebody go tickle a
[ __ ] honestly you know I hate to
use that language at this time of year
but go tickle a [ __ ] because
humans are one of the few animals that
have the ability to jumpstart our own
joy and that's by tickling some animals
you see them are different you know
species they can't do anything if they
want to laugh they have no recourse they
have no way to ought to autumn to start
that up themselves you know I'm saying
if you see a little uh you know you see
a little chimpanzee outside
well they smile a lot they smile but if
you see a different type of animal an
aardvark a raccoon an opossum those
[ __ ] ain't finding any joy but
imagine if you could go up and squeeze
their sides and they started to laugh
well humans are the only species that
have that built into them that we know
of so so to utilize that tickle somebody
you love touch them baby touch that
little [ __ ] and beat and make
somebody feel good make somebody kick
start that joy you know when I was young
we played when I was young I remember
tickling was fun but also
you know our when we were in our family
we was dangerous you know and if
somebody especially if you had man this
is a dark episode for Christmas but when
I was young if you had a little bit of
diarrhea you know it you know I'm saying
diarrhea you know when your booty is
trying to attack you from the you know
from everywhere and when your booty does
is angry at you and if you had some of
that when I was young you wouldn't tell
my brothers and sisters because they
would try to tickle you because we had
that thing in our house where if
somebody had the Big D you know then
other people would try to tickle and
make them real active and make them you
know lose it right there so that was a
very in nefarious time if you had you
know if you had it you had to keep it a
secret she had to be real secretive and
it's hard to have that to possess that
demon that body demon and and also be
secretive because I mean honestly heaven
diarrhea is kind of the opposite of
keeping a secret
you know diarrhea doesn't want to be a
secret if you know that or not but happy
Holidays to you guys what's going on I
got here into ok came into New Orleans
we got the show on the 26th everybody's
pretty keyed up and I came into to the
airport here and they're building a new
airport finally in New Orleans I mean
the International Airport here is one
where I mean it's I wouldn't even it
makes you when you get here it makes you
want to get back on a plane and go
somewhere else right when you get to the
airport very dirty hasn't been mopped I
feel like in decades probably it's that
type of environment kind of an it almost
seems unbel like if you put a mop on the
floor of the floor would just kind of
chuckle at you it just kind of has that
sort of environment but God in the town
state in New Orleans went to a party now
went to a party a friend of mine had a
party and or he went to a party and he
invited me and I'm called a plus-one at
that point they
you a plus-one and the party man I'll be
honest with you everybody not everybody
at the party but 92% of the party were
homoerotic men and I mean look some I'm
beautiful you know some I'm okay looking
but dude I had it was just one of those
things where I couldn't barely eat or
look around the room really without
locking eyes with a real bad boy you
know it's sometimes man I feel like a
gay guy can see all your secrets if
they're looking at you and that makes me
feel some time kind of wild you know and
here's the thing the main appetizer they
had soup so man you trying to get some
soup down and you got to like put your
lips out a little bit to get soup
because soup is one of those you know
one of those things you almost have to
meet it halfway some things you can just
you know whatever but soup you got to
you got to make that little duck with
your mouth and get out there and meet it
halfway and then at the end they had a
tray of um sweets like a sweet area and
it was a bunch of cream puffs and I
don't know if you ever had cream puffs
it's cream basically hiding inside of a
little bit of dough and if you didn't
know him you weren't familiar with cream
puffs you wouldn't know the cream was in
them somebody has to tell you almost hey
there's cream in there and then you open
one up or you bite into it and there is
cream but man I had to go up to over to
that dessert area and they had a flock
of dudes around that deal and I'm not I
got no issues with gay men you know I'm
saying I might be gay when I'm 70 or 80
or 90 or a hundred and you know or
something or you know or 70 but you know
it's still I'm a guy so I know what guys
are thinking about and if I go by a guy
and I'm trying to get a couple of cream
puffs in me real quick without them
noticing but
dude you can't a man can't eat a
creampuff around a game man without that
man noticing I mean it's almost like he
could hear every bite and man it was
just tough it was I've never been on
Fear Factor but you know I had about
nine cream puffs and there was a whole
circle of gay men right there and and it
was hard to swallow brother and we just
heard just a lot of different levels
going on
you know levels but I want to thank you
guys for uh for being here with me today
what's going on the football the Saints
beat on the Saints beat Pittsburgh and
I'm sorry about that game honestly I
love my Saints but I also think that
they referees made some bad calls in
that one I'll say that any day of the
week and that's it man I'm down here for
the holidays you know I'm just um I went
for a run today they have a big lake
down here I don't know what it's called
but mmm I don't think it has a name it's
just called you know just a lake but
it's huge and you can run around it you
could walk around it or do anything you
could dry you could do anything around
it but what I did today was run around
it in and it's nice out there and they
got all kind of animals out there you
see a little raccoon on the side of them
of it eating a little fish or something
having a little piece of trout or a
little you know cut a gar or a little
filet you know her a little tilapia the
where did tilapia come from remember do
when I was young they had like three
types of fish catfish sharks what else
tarpon suddenly like six years ago they
got tilapia like what the heck
then it's like now they got a new fish
called we fish or something it's like oh
you ir qu e or qu I like what is that
like where they find a new fish at
I mean it's like who the who I mean do
we live in a dr. Seuss book how they
suddenly just finding a new fish so just
like you know that's the thing I guess
things always have to be new but they're
always like I noticed the other day I'm
at the UM Starbuck and they have they
say the Suvi that little they got little
eggs in there something and they say
that the way they cook him is sooo V and
what dude I knew growing up this lady
named sue V was this lady to live about
probably three doors down from us she
was an alcoholic and she drove a Crest
toothpaste blue Trans Am and she come
home and get drunk and just go lay out
on the top of that thing have a couple
cigarettes she'd have her skirt on bro
but nothing under that thing you know
and she was just I mean she was sex ed
she was sex education wrapped up into a
person but that made her feel something
you know I mean if you have a six-pack
and lay on top of a damn Trans Am and
have you a couple cigarettes and you you
know you got a skirt on but you ain't
but they ain't much else on except a
little you know maybe you just wearing a
couple of uh Inklings of the devil then
that's that's a statement
you know everybody want to act like you
know if somebody's you know out there
tramping or doing this or that that
that's all they are but that's a real
statement if you ask me that's a real
statement if you ask me man it's the end
of the year it goes fast huh kind of all
over the place today but I don't want to
take up a ton of you guys this time you
know I mean it's Christmas and I went
you don't want us all to spend time with
our families and think of joy and think
of good times
then don't tickle anybody if that guy
dying I'm ringing him right that was the
worst part
cuz here's the thing in my house like if
you had it first of all you had to tell
mom because you wanted to get better mom
had medicines she had you know ice pack
or something you know I said cuz I look
I grew up in a place didn't have a ton
of medicine when I was young I remember
if you have real bad diarrhea at school
they put you in a in a like an ice
bucket like an ice tub with water in
there you know what the huh but they
said the pressure from the water with
the ice in it your body doesn't want to
expel you know duty you know but you
know body dirt you know body body dirty
it doesn't want to blow that body dirty
out of your body because the water the
cold water the pressure from it will
keep you from doing that so I guess
sometimes that can like bring down your
temperature and I guess that was
something that would help but when I got
older they had you know a moxie cycling
amoxicillin different pills different
types of pills and pill a tree so anyhow
I got that yeah yeah and you had to
sneak to mom's room and you had to tell
mom secretively and sometimes I would
just write it down because if anybody
heard you do my siblings if any one of
us had it the other ones would come and
just tickle the [ __ ] out of them oh you
got diarrhea boy then you about to end
man it's a powerful moment when you are
laughing uncontrollably when you're
really when you're doing things
uncontrollably out of two parts of your
body it's a very moving experience it's
kind of like man vs. wild a little bit
if you've ever seen that show it's like
that but it's just you and your body and
somebody's tickling
what else oh I watched your show on
Netflix I think everybody's watching
this it's called the innocent man and
it's about well it's about some dudes
that's allegedly innocent and it talks
about being just like if you spent death
row or you spent your life in prison I
don't know what I would do if I was in
prison you know one of my friends the
other day said that he missed being in
prison because he missed the structure
of it and I could see that a little bit
like I could go to a nice prison you
know if people are friendly if there's
like a pickup League if you know if they
have dessert sometimes I could go to
something like that and if they had a
gym or an you know a workout area or
something a place you could get a little
bit of sunshine those are things I could
deal with my but I think if it was
something beyond that man it'd be too
much for me you know I don't want to be
in a gang I don't want to get [ __ ]
cut open I don't want to fight a bunch
of Mexican or black dudes really or
angry you know white supremacist you
know uh I guess I couldn't handle it
probably but if it were like a kind of a
chill if you I would love like the
camaraderie the teamwork kind of working
in one of the shops I love arts and
crafts
it's basically a kindergarten but people
are fighting a lot I would guess but
yeah if you get to watch this show the
innocent men on Netflix it's pretty good
man I love these murder shows you know I
love these investigations into old
crimes
buried treasure you guys know I love all
of that amulets I mean now for my
honeymoon if I ever get married I want
to go looking for for buried treasure
you know if I ever get married so we'll
see what you know what God has in store
for me but merry Christmas to you guys
and a Happy New Year I'm gonna play a
couple of calls that came in I do
he was crispy and I am from Waterloo
Iowa I can't stop smiling
oh hello thank you for calling Christy
and I love Iowa it's the only state that
has for 75% of the name of the state is
vowels homeward I just wanted to call
and tell you about my weekend because it
was truly just the best weekend ever and
I'm just so happy so on further this
past weekend
my boyfriend and I celebrated five years
of being a couple and we also both
graduated from college so he graduated
with his master's and occupational
therapy and I graduated with my
associates degree in culinary arts
Oh congratulations that's teamwork right
there you guys sound like you're really
attacking the world together as
individuals but also as teammates so
congratulations on that onward I get
nervous too especially if I have you
know what and I'm trying to tell my mo
am about it and my brothers and sisters
are feeling like tickling homework I'm
Saturday we had a and you had all of our
family and friends there and can you
propose to me and so yeah we're getting
married and I just I can't wait and it's
going to be the best thing ever so we're
also moving across the country to
Portland Oregon so that's coming up here
in in the next ten days and we're so
excited to start on your adventure wow
you guys well congratulations first and
foremost that is quite a weekend and I
feel like you're you're calling from
like 1910 or 1930 or something you know
or 1890 you know you guys just finished
school you're getting married and now
you're moving across the plains all
within the next you know within the next
ten days that's an adventure
man you got a that's a lot of adventure
at once and that's a lot of adventure
once but you sound like you're filled
with joy you know and that's the time is
this is the time year to have that and
you got it and I appreciate you calling
and sharing a little bit of that with us
you know means a lot of lonely straight
dudes listening to this podcast
including me I usually listen to it so
to know that there's a hope out there or
finding a gal getting or educated and
getting her out to Oregon you know to
work on a weed farm or whatever plan you
guys have that's beautiful you know
that's truly beautiful and thank you for
calling and congratulations to you guys
on your nuptials let's take another call
right here that came in the hotline and
I want to I want to refine this a little
that this call I was listening to some
old episodes and if you're a man who is
struggling with something you know you
got something on your mind on your heart
or on even on your nuts really not on
the outside like that a dermatologist
needs to see but something you know that
just keeps kind of just nudging the
inside of your nuts you can call me and
you can hit the hotline with it because
I've been down some dark roads daddy
okay I've been in the shade I've been in
the shadows alright I got moon burn from
some dirty nights and I want to tell you
that if you're willing to share
something and I can relate to it I'm
happy to share my experience and my
strength and hope with you the number is
always as ninety five six six four nine
five zero three that could be any man
who's struggling with you know maybe
you're you're caught up in some lies
you've been doing crime you are new you
having sexual issues sexual dysfunction
or malfunction you just got a cat and
you're thinking about getting a cat you
don't want to tell anybody anything
menthol whatever recipes whatever you
need I am here for you and this is a
safe place for you and for me and that's
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero
three let's take this call CEO Han
calling in about that twenty
three-year-old who wants to know what he
should do about the thirty nine-year-old
keep sexing him and her husband is
paralyzed Brock oh yes thank you this
call came in last week we had a young
man who has been sexting with an older
woman and the older woman's husband is
paralyzed you know locked down you know
it's a little chair daddy and and and no
the wife wants to do sex with the
younger boy and he's of age he's not
illegal and and this is a call a
response to that
oh what you done missed a mark on this
one man [ __ ] somebody else's wife is
the original dark are you can't be
telling 23 year olds to run around [ __ ]
another guy's wife even if the disc
don't work because I got it caught in
like an escalator accident that's not
the way this [ __ ] works that 23 year
old man you're young you don't know what
the [ __ ] you doing yet you know what
you're dabbling in you've got some 39
year old nice lady wants to [ __ ]
touch a hey gang and that's great I'll
[ __ ] put the phone down actually
delete her number and then put the phone
down if she ever needs to make that
arrangement where her and her husband
are gonna find some guys for her to [ __ ]
they'll both be a part of it she's
slipping you in on the side and you
don't fully realize how tough eight ways
from Sunday that really is in a couple
years I think you probably figured it
out but right now there's [ __ ] plenty
of [ __ ] in Florida wherever the [ __ ]
you're at and everywhere can be Florida
if you want it to be you know if you
caught up in enough dope or whatever you
know bad son if you got a lot of sunburn
or you know plop you know plausible son
cancer or something anything anybody you
can make Florida anywhere you know you
know you get a pack of menthols and lay
in a yard in this Florida but yet you
know what that really is a good
suggestion because you know and maybe I
have failed this youngster but I was
saying that you should present it to the
husband and just make sure that he is in
on the good with it so that you guys
aren't milling around behind here
you know hurt back or whatever I don't
know exactly how to phrase that but see
you are milling behind his you know so
he's not just sitting facing one way
facing the window or whatever you guys
are back behind him because yeah that's
gonna well here's the thing if you do it
and you don't get some approval first
then you're definitely gonna make some
bad karma for yourself and karma has a
long memory karma keeps a list do karma
has a lot of ink and they're gonna
remember what they what you did so yeah
maybe I think you're right I think maybe
to take this man's suggestion as opposed
to mind even though I think mine was
that you should get some approval to go
meet with the with the paralyzed man and
get his well wishes first that would be
the manly thing to do you know talk to
him face to face and say you know look
this is what's going on and it may be a
little odd that the woman chose you and
didn't chose a man more her age but I
don't know what she's into and I'm not
sure how old the paralyzed man is either
so a couple of different X factors they
call those X factors
let me tell you guys this though I I'm
coming up to Omaha you know that Phoenix
all those tickets are on sale theof on
Comm slash tour tou are I also want to
tell you that today's episode is brought
to you by me undies you know
Christmastime is a great time to have
something under your tree and a lot of
people under their tree they have well
under their body they kind of have a
knot there under their body but in the
middle kind of under part of their body
they have their crotch and the best
thing you can put your crotch in as me
undies I'll tell you that I've put my
crotch into some some real temperamental
situations and the softest and most
reliable and trustworthy thing I've ever
put my crotch in is me undies me undies
are special underwear the best underwear
they use micromo dow fabric it's three
times softer than regular cotton do
that's basically space fabric think of
going to space now think about wrapping
some of that space around your junk
Buzz Lightyear me Indies releases
multiple fun prints each month and they
have matching socks and bra let's case
you are a woman with breasts or a man
with breasts there's a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee you're gonna love
these undies and if you're not into them
just send them back for a full refund
they also have a new membership program
we can just get that repetition
underwear on they just keep them coming
keep them coming and to support this
past weekend which I would love for you
to do you will get 15% off your first
pair and free shipping and a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee go to
meet undies dot-com slash weekend
that's mend1677 it was like a you know
just like a like a hard you know square
something but they didn't know what and
so I don't think we realize dude I
remember they had a man in our town who
tried to only teach a teacher he tried
to take it easy and only teach half the
alphabet to his class and then all the
words he gave him on tests and using
sentences in the class only were from
the first half of the alphabet and they
fired him because he was trying to make
life easy on himself but think about
that you know so just don't take it for
granted if you can read or spell
you know all more Chris thanks for
calling I just want to let you know
you're always asking what kind of
collars or how Lister's are out there
listening to you once you know you got a
lot of truck drivers let me tell you
what you play to myself oh yeah we got
to play that horn again wrong word one
more time so y'all just so pleased the
old barn I'm just tired that's full over
taking out whatever now I just turn that
podcast on get that heater get it keep
on truckin just turn that podcast on
just dad hit it just bone trucking in
there hey do we really appreciate
everything you do for style depreciation
to get good paint just keep on keepin on
thank you partner
hey Theo this busy boy Krillin I'm gonna
go right to the end of that and get that
horn one more time dude don't want that
horn baby I used to love it myself
yes thank you Chris and I hope you were
honking in a damn Subaru you know I hope
you were honking it just a bunch of
named youngsters they were trying to do
coke off the dashboard and you just
really wrecked up that eight ball yeah
man I wonder what it's like out there
sometimes you know when I was young we
would drive by semis you know semi
trucks and we'd always you know you had
to show if you would show your junk or
it did you like this with your hand and
you know make that pull down sign and
they would sound that horn off and one
time man I'll never forget this man they
had a lady driver and I'd never seen one
and I don't know who the first one first
female trucker was you know Jericho
janitor probably had some you know wild
name but she had I swear - I swear - she
had the biggest a pace mega steadies day
Big D's Oh Minkus
no who's there big babies bro she had
them hefty hefty bangbang as you feel me
where's the beef
and she I remember it as dude I remember
seeing two times I've seen some nudity
and this was one time this lady lifted
one of them big through her mouth and
trying to lick the nipple try to lick
her own nipple with her tongue and
couldn't do it that's what I remember
she couldn't pull it off you know she
was trying to do a little bit of that
you know cert so tit and and she
couldn't pull it off but but I loved it
man thank you guys for hauling stuff
back and forth everybody wants to just
pretend that things automatically get
places that magic moves things around no
people do decent people and semi decent
people thank you Chris
literally semi decent semi decent bad
joke
but thank you men to drive safe out
there dude and if you got to go out in a
blaze of glory dog here's what I say you
do fill the back of that semi with
gasoline or kerosene like that match up
and drive straight into the enemy and
who's the enemy pick one whoever you
want it to be brother let's take another
call here we go
hi feel my belly I'm calling from
Colorado Springs hey jelly thank you for
calling merry Christmas to you all
homeward I'm going through a lot I just
think about that my husband has been
cheating on me and the stay-at-home mom
of three small perfect human beings and
I'm trying to navigate now through life
without this man I thought was perfect
so I I mop and clean a hospital at night
when the kids are sleeping I'm trying to
figure out how to make an income to
survive on my own you
it's really a struggle and your podcast
and listening to you and your humor have
really helped get me through it and I
hope you never stop being you because
you are so helpful and I just wanted to
say case you because it just seems like
every time I listen your podcast it's
like talking to a friend well that's
sweet of you to say that and thank you
for working hard you know so your kids
will have some opportunities you know
and thank you for not you know I never
been in that situation where where
that's going on you know I'm not even
brave enough to get into a marriage but
you know I could imagine that when you
get into that situation and you get
divorced or separated or whatever that
some people probably you know just well
you it's probably an opportunity to
really give up on yourself you know to
fail you could fail you know you to even
failure to fail your children you know
because it's just the pressure and maybe
feeling you know the rejection that you
know your husband may have made you feel
but I bet it's pretty powerful for you
to stay in there and keep keep your head
up and keep moving forward I think it's
pretty amazing and it's kind of neat
because it's almost like I get to talk
to my own mom for a second back then and
you know if had any suggestion I would
just say you know just make sure to just
spend a little bit of time extra with
your kids when you can one-on-one so
that they feel you know a personal
connection with you laughing with them
that can help as long as y'all are
laughs and it doesn't matter and and
that's it and that's and that's all I
know but it's nice of you to say you
know it's really nice you to say that I
appreciate that and and I appreciate you
being a hard-working lady and you know I
think a lot of good opportunities are
gonna come your way
merry Christmas to you guys let's take
another call that that came in here here
we go you know this is Dylan and sent
from New York
calling in after hearing you asked about
experiences with animals during sex so
I've got a six month seven month old
pitbull and my girlfriend and I always
have a problem where if we decide to get
it on this dog straight out starts
pulling blankets up before this pause
you can't control himself he just starts
going ham on her he wants to [ __ ]
brother I mean if you're [ __ ] he
wants to as well brother homework
sometimes even me I've had him literally
lick my balls lick her [ __ ]
anything he's [ __ ] did yet to say
[ __ ] you could have just said ass
let's hear more thank you for calling in
an animal look he is an animal literally
yeah it's hilarious but it's not so
uncomfortable I don't know what to do
about it
seven months old and he's hornier than
me anyway love your [ __ ] and preciate
listening to the podcast first time
calling in hopefully it gets on the show
yeah it did get on man and thank you for
calling in and I'll say this brother
yeah he's seven months old but imagine
if you were seven months old and could
[ __ ] like that dog can imagine that like
when we're seven months we can't do
anything we can barely hold it hold it
City you could barely hold it hit it in
your mouth but imagine that at seven
months you can do work and on to lamb in
a dam a pitbull it'll rip you know it'll
rip a kid's face off in Florida with one
with one side of its body and [ __ ] with
the other I mean they're multifaceted so
just imagine that and if you were seven
month old imagine a seven month old baby
that could [ __ ] it would be [ __ ]
everything but it can't God does want to
put that much power into a baby if
somewhere that cute and could [ __ ]
everybody will [ __ ] it there's no hot
chick out there that wouldn't honestly
[ __ ] a seven month old baby and I don't
mean that in a perverted type of way I
mean that in a straight-up real way
that something is cute as a
seven-month-old baby that could bug that
had a you know a pee on an adult penis
and could really throw some some meat
boy yeah so but thank you for calling
man and look I would get you a little
chain link or something get you a little
chain link fence even inside you know I
live I lived in a neighborhood and
there's and people down the street from
us and the man was an Elvis impersonator
and he ended up I think he died probably
I never saw him die but when I first met
him I knew right when I met him he
wasn't gonna live very long but they had
chain-link fence inside their house
because they wanted their dogs to be
able to be inside but only in certain
areas so you could also do a fence and
in the house Oh weird let's take another
call hey what's going on Tanner from
Texas man thank you for calling brother
merry Christmas to you a year and two
months now so I stopped smoking weed to
get a good job really bothered me too
much recently recently alright
everything kind of feels boring like
stuck at home like smoke like there's
nothing to do so he's getting me like
advised like everything feels boring now
when I kid hanging out with Mike no I
appreciate the call brother
you know if someone told me one time if
you're bored you're boring and you got
to make stuff for yourself to do we live
in an exciting world there's exciting
opportunities there's information
everywhere you know you got a baby right
there look I agree it's probably fun to
get high around a baby you know won't we
I don't think you should do coke or
anything else psychedelic by a baby but
if you and the baby are in a safe place
and you want to take one hit off of
something I understand I could see how
it would be enjoyable but with that said
you got to make your own excitement in
the world and you might be just at one
of those little plateaus in life you
know brother I'll say this that there's
a lot of just little plateaus in life
where you just get a little bored you
know even coming home this holiday
season it's like I everything was a
little bit of a plateau kind of like
like things are you know nice my family
is all healthy and everybody's doing
good and you know my little niece was
you know won an award at school and my
little nephews are like turning into
like different humans and you know a lot
of neat stuff but you know sometimes you
just hit like you go back to a place
you're like oh it's it's uh you know
it's just I've hit a plateau or
something
like kind of like you know whenever you
come home from college in the summer a
bunch and it's fun and it's fun and then
you come home you get out of college and
you still come home once in a while and
it's not as fun people started getting
married and things started changing and
not as many people come home for the
summer and then like eventually you come
home one you know you're still somebody
who comes home around the holidays and
nobody's really around anymore and
you're like well what happened and it's
just life you know life just happened
everything's still great but it's just
it's different you know and and that
could be what's going on maybe you're
all over all you're just having a moment
where you have a note you're you'd be
able to look at things a little like
things are different now with that say
you also might just want to [ __ ] get
some fortnight or something going or get
some Red Dead Redemption I'm thinking
about buying some video games so you
know but I would also spend this time
and join it with your little one do some
face painting do some you know do some
massage they got a thing on the internet
how to safely massage your child you
know they have a lot of stuff like that
do some
you could do outdoor kind of strength
and conditioning work I don't know how
strong the baby is or if the baby you
know enjoys you know you think has a
future in athletics but I saw some stuff
on YouTube
what else do haircuts they got all kind
of fun haircuts you can do on a child
and yourself what if y'all get matching
cuts matching outfits
I think it's a great time to embrace
that your child's youth and do some
exciting things with it and if you're
getting bored man I would say challenge
yourself you know the one good way is to
challenge yourself and another thing is
just do some contrary action if somebody
asks you to go do something instead of
thinking oh man I don't want to do that
that's boring just say yes even if it's
something small or something silly
something that sounds dumb to you
because if you do some contrary action
things will change you know but whatever
is going on you have to change things
you have to be the catalyst that
catalysts that caddy cat you know
nothing changes if nothing changes
nothing changes if nothing changes so
let's take another call but thank you
for calling brother and make sure you be
a good parent first and it sounds like
you are so I think you love your kid it
sound like you know you just got some
youth going through your veins and try
not to do a lot of jerk and all your
canal let's take another call hey Theo
what this is Lia calling from Dallas
Texas what up Lia and I'll be there
January 26 through 28 in Addison I'll be
back almond I was calling because I just
finished listening to your podcast
there's something about Mary and the guy
was asking if he's gay because he likes
things up his ass and it just made me
laugh I had to call in and say because
my friend is a nurse she's an ER nurse
and she tells me stories constantly
about men that come into the ER and come
into the ER sometimes women but mainly
men who come into the ER because they
have something they were like putting
something in their ass and it got stuck
and it was in it's trapped and they have
to like do surgery on it or most of the
time because it gets so far up in there
yeah and they used to call they used to
say you playing hat when I was young and
say you playing happy meal if you're
hiding stuff in your but when I was
young they say you playing happy meal I
said what you doing over there playing
with your happy meal and that's when I
was real young you know and if he was if
they said you're playing with your happy
meal that mean you was playing with your
butthole do you know doing something you
shouldn't be doing with your butt and
here's the thing people's butts people's
butter was it's like a secret area it's
like a cave it's like a mystery area if
it were in front of you you don't you
look in there and go in there and hide
stuff in there but it's around back of
you so if you put something in there
sometimes you don't know where it is you
know it's kind of like a trapper keeper
but it really doesn't let you have your
stuff back and butt holes is magical and
unique you know it's really the last
realm because people aren't really doing
that much sex anymore as much vagina sex
as they used to so they're doing more
you know annal sex or butt sex and then
once that's done what's next after that
we're just going to be virtual reality
or people are gonna get a new orifice I
think installed on their body and I
don't know where that would go
it could be underarms it could be the
side of your thighs it could be
something you hook on the front of your
head and people [ __ ] that or whatever
but a lot of unique opportunities out
there let's take a little more your call
they can't get it out and a lot of times
like the guys will even come in with
their wives like this one dude was like
jacking off on a toilet or something and
like stuck a little tooth like
toothpaste holder toothbrush holder in
there they got stuck up his ass
and his wife was in there with him oh
yeah and that's that long floss that's
that long floss right there well yes his
wife came with him because here's why if
he doesn't bring his wife in then the
people in there gonna say this man's
gays a game a
and he's in you know he's doing cocaine
and stuff like that he's you know doing
perversions
you know he's back behind the shown he's
jerking off when I was young when they
used to have men would go meet up behind
or not meet up but they would go parked
behind the winn-dixie and masturbate
sometimes and cry in their trunks but
those days are over and I guess this is
the new that hiding things in your butt
on the toilet so you know every time you
want to think you manatees really going
a long way and this and that they're not
there you know we're really just people
that like to play with our you know that
happy me you feeling oh you over there
playing would you happy meet huh I mean
it cuz honestly that is the final
frontier let's take one more call here
here we go hey yo hope you're doing good
this is heaven from Boulder Colorado
what's up Evan and we got a lot of calls
coming in from high altitude this week
and I don't know if that could be where
the earth is or shape you know what's up
with the you know I don't know [ __ ]
let's hear more so I noticed you talking
about how are you and your brother
weren't very close for a very long time
and how you just recently done sort of a
new relationship almost seems like well
me and my brother like 11 years apart
and we've never been that close he lives
in Texas right now so I don't even get
to see him very often so I was just
wondering maybe some of the things you
and your brother did to become closer
and to develop a better relationship if
anyone else could chime in on that that
would be great too Thanks Theo keep up
the good work man I've been listening to
this podcast for a while now and it is
by far my favorite thanks brother gang
man Gang Gang merry Christmas to you bro
gang bruh triple triple triple gang you
know I think it's sweet that you want to
have a better relationship with your
brother
I think expressing that to him would be
a good place to start
you know just telling him flat-out I
mean sometimes it's hard to just say
that kind of stuff you know say hey you
know I'd like to have a closer
relationship with you man it's really
gonna probably that's really gonna
probably hit him right in the heart I
think creating like one thing that he
and I do is you know we both like the
Saints we have a common bond there with
the New Orleans Saints and we'll talk
about the Saints games we talk about
growing up we talk about things that
happened when we were young
we kind of get each other things that
are meaningful for Christmas you know
the holidays do things like that you
know my brother sometimes it feels he
feels he has some tough moments
sometimes when he looks at pictures of
himself from being young and he's not
happy in any of them he's not smiled and
he's not showing any emotion and so I
got him this year I got ma a little
jacket or a little sweat jacket little
not a sweater but a soft hoodie and it
says Kid Dynamite on it and it's nice
it's a cool like pieces from this
company roots of fight and they have
some really neat stuff actually and but
you know I saw that and I just told him
I said hey and it was hard I told him I
said hey this is uh I know sometimes you
don't know if you were you know a fun
kid or not or if you were having fun
when you were a kid so I got you this
because I want I wanted you to you know
to think that you were and it's funny
because that was my plan and then I gave
him the gift and right before I was
gonna give it to him I'm like man I'm
not gonna say all that gay [ __ ] you know
I think he's saying that [ __ ] to the
dude I'm just gonna give him the damn
you know jacket piece but I said it I
didn't really say it as direct as I
wanted to I kind of set it in Pat you
know not in passing but you know he was
sitting down and I was
standing up and there was a lot of
commotion in the room but I did say it
and I made sure that he heard me and
just let him know so I think something
like that like no matter what you're
doing make sure your message is heard
you know if you just try to call them
you know you can try to make efforts but
sometimes you know like to call them you
know every once a week or to spend time
doing that kind of stuff or maybe make a
plan to visit but I think just letting
him know straight up you know I'd love
to have more of a relationship with you
what do you think we can do and that's
mano a mano right there he's probably
gonna feel a lot of respect for you even
just as a man
and especially since he's a little bit
older than you but I wish you the best
with that you know and I think the fact
that you're even calling you even care
that much has to be that's good stuff
because brothers can do a lot of things
to other each other that other people
can't you know I mean who else really
can honestly tickle the diarrhea right
out of you and that's a brother that's a
brother that can do that y'all could
also get matching hats or do some [ __ ]
like that like they do like in Norway
and stuff you know them dudes will get
matching hats and [ __ ] they'll get a
belt that keeps both of a minute she'll
see them but they got one Keelung belt
in there you know both in the same belt
like what in the [ __ ] bra you know but
that keeps them close you know you could
get a necklace that's really long and
both you guys wear it at the same time
there's some you know those are more
those aren't as scientific ideas I don't
think but those are a little bit more
you know old-school kind of German ideas
almost but I wish you well man and I
think that this is a time of year where
you can let somebody know you care and
it's not awkward I mean it's a beautiful
time of year and I'm I am thankful to
you guys I'm thankful to my producers
and I'm looking forward to an exciting
year next year and people ask a lot of
times we'll deal when you're gonna do
another Netflix
nobody's offering that stuff so if it
gets offered I will consider it but
until that kind of stuff gets offered
it's not gonna it's nothing nothing I
can address you know what else any other
questions people have been asking a lot
of Oh King in the sting Christmas Day so
be prepared for that it's coming out and
we're looking forward to giving that to
you and with that said man I want to
wish you guys a Merry Christmas thank
you guys for being here for me I'm happy
to be a part of your lives and and I
hope you have a lot of joy this year
today tomorrow whenever you know I hope
like that young man that is called in if
you have you know a sibling that you
know if you're that older brother of
someone reach out to you know maybe the
voice of this young man let's go back to
his call for a very long time and have
you just recently done sort of a new
relationship almost seems like well me
and my brother are like 11 years apart
and we've never been that close he lives
in Texas right now so I don't even get
to see him very often who was that in
your family you know that the young man
that's calling here there might be one
of those in your family or in your life
you know somebody who wants to have a
better relationship with you you know so
instead of you know letting this you
know letting the member of your family
end up calling in here which I'm glad
that this young man did let me catch his
name again a CEO I hope you're doing
good this is heaven from Boulder Cup
Evan so there's an Evan in your life
somewhere it wants to get in touch with
you who wants to talk with you who wants
to be closer to you so you know cut them
off at the pass reach out to somebody
tell them you love them you know reach
out to somebody tell them you care give
somebody an extra hug tickle the dang
diary out of somebody it's that time of
year merry Christmas to you and yours
I'm not sure if we can ever
regular episode next week we may I'm
just not even sure yet but I'll see you
guys in New Orleans and then I'll see
you guys in Omaha and Phoenix coming up
and Australia I will see you guys in May
those aren't on sale yet I don't think
but Merry Christmas and and happy
Kwanzaa Happy Hanukkah happy anything
you use anything you celebrate and I
love you guys happy holidays
[Music]
my Christmas